I like rugby but I'm not a good player
at it there are some interesting
consequences of the rules I want to
explore and this is actually a famous
piece of Applied maths about a real
world sporting problem and I'll explain
some of the rules here just for clarity
uh you can score points by putting the
ball down over a line it's called a try
very like an American football a
touchdown point about this though is
that once you've scored a try in rugby
you then also get a chance to get some
bonus points with what they call a
conversion where you kick over the posts
so full disclosure American football you
put the ball down over the as a
touchdown you then get to take the kick
from in front of the post is that right
I think that's right uh yes never played
American football but I'm reliably
informed in rugby you cannot do that you
have to take the conversion kick
somewhere in line with where you put the
ball down so if you put the ball down
right at the edge of the pitch like
close to the the touch line which is
quite common because people are sort of
bleeding you out there as you get
tackled you have to take a kick really
close to the touchline but you can
choose how far back to take in that is
our question if you have the choice
which you do every time you score try
how far back should you take the kick if
you are really close if you like then
you can imagine the post being at a
weird angle but if you go really far
back I mean technically I think you can
go to the other end of the pitch but I
don't think it would be clever for range
reasons
um even if you are a good cooker unlike
me
no we can't
it's in
it's time the real issue is that maybe
your advice should change so let's get
this one thing out of the way if you put
the try Down Under the posts you have to
take the kick in line with that and
there isn't really a problem here you
just go back far enough that you can get
it over the bar and there's no worry
because the further back you go the
narrower the angle looks because you're
further away obviously if you're trying
to take it from the try line itself
you're going to struggle to clear the
thing but it's the first modeling thing
I want to get out of the way is that
let's just assume that under the post is
not a problem you take it close enough
and you're fine if you put a try down to
the side of the posts and this is where
I want to show you on the diagram so
here's a picture of rugby pitch I've got
a nice 3D model uh I think you might
recognize the software this is jojobra
so this point here is where it's called
the try and you have to take a kick
somewhere in line with that and if I
move this point
the line moves up we just talked about
going under the posts no big deal so
it's if you're to the side of the post
you can imagine taking the kick from
over here
looks a bit difficult if I sort of Zoom
The View around like it's a terrible
angle
but if you take the kick from really
really far away it's arguable that
maybe you've got a better angle but the
range starts to become an issue and if
you go really far away like way down the
other end of the pitch
the goal is just a really long way away
and even if the range isn't a problem
the angle is narrowing because you're
getting further away from it so the
question I have here is how do you best
get the angle of the posts to be
maximized
because that's going to be what matters
for your accuracy of the kick there are
some other things like can you clear the
crossbar we've talked about that a bit
if you're too close it's going to be
tricky incidentally there is there's a
five meter line on the rugby pitches
here
and I think a good rule of thumb is that
the angle most people kick at about 30
degrees they say as long as you're a
distance the other side of that line
you're likely to be able to clear the
crossbar so we can just dodge that part
of the model you're saying if you're
closer than that it's almost too steep
yeah you're going to have to sort of do
a proper chip and actually that's really
hard to give any power anyway and it's
just unnatural
um I looked up apparently 30 degrees is
roughly what a good kicker will kick at
and about 26 meters per second goes a
long way so you mean 30 degrees up not
30 degrees 30 degrees elevation yeah
um everyone thinks that 45 degrees is
the best but it turns out if you as a
kicker if you kick a name to do 45
degrees you lose a lot of power because
it's not the way your your leg moves so
this is the real model of ego look at
the rugby players and they kick it about
30 degrees
and that also is going to solve a
problem with range is that if they do
that and they're professionals they can
kick a long way like maybe Beyond 30
meters which means even if you went to
the halfway line there's still a chance
that you could get it long enough if you
could I'm aware that I should probably
go and try this but uh I don't think I
could do that
but that means the modeling is really
how do you get the best angle and the
extremes are I know you like thinking
about extremes if you're really close to
the try line the angle is going to be
really narrow we saw on the on there and
if you're really far away it's also
going to be narrow somewhere in the
middle is an Optimum and that sounds
like a task for maths so that's our job
the first thing to do is to draw some
diagrams so I'm going to show on here a
angle
here is the angle they call it the angle
subtended um most people have never
heard that word unless they remember
some circle theorem from school but it's
the angle that the posts make to your
point here and you see that actually the
measurement here if I'm really close to
the trailer location the angle's down to
three degrees that's the super narrow
angle and if you're really far away it
goes down to single digits as well but
somewhere in the middle I'm into double
digits 10.11 degrees angle that's
looking like a best place but where is
the best place and does it change when
you move your try location around yes
and I don't think it's obvious so I if
you interview rugby players about where
they do it I am sure that they are
solving this problem every day without
doing a hefty amount of maths but if you
got down to it and this is now big
business in sport getting those margins
optimized even if there's a place that
you should take it from and then you
adjust for your range and the wind
distance and how tired you're feeling it
would be good knowledge and I think we
should solve it let me draw a rugby
pitch those are this is my idealized
goal posts and let's say we're working
here and you score try there this is the
line that you are allowed to take a kick
from and just to clarify let's say you
take the kick from here then this angle
is what we're trying to maximize
call it Theta let's call it Theta
really close in the angle is going to be
tiny really far away the angle gets
smaller as well there must be some
optimal thing how do we find it now you
could do this the long way I recommend
it as an exercise for any interested
parties you'd need some calculus because
we're optimizing we're maximizing
something and it gets super messy so
don't do it unless you're brave there's
a better way and this is quite common in
mathematics is that sometimes you just
need to draw a better picture there's a
few things you should know this is the
distance between the posts actually I
think it's 5.6 meters if you change the
rules of rugby though we can still work
with d and the distance we score the
Triad I'm going to call X and that's to
the middle of the post so it feels like
a good place to measure where you score
the try so that's our variable X and
what we're trying to decide
is this distance here let's call it y
how far should you Pace back with the
ball and take your kick yeah so
mathematically we're trying to find a
function uh of X so y equals something
to do with X practically you said
exactly the same thing which is how fast
should you go back from where you put it
down any three points you put on paper
or anywhere else you can draw a circle
three a unique circle three three points
and there are three points we care about
here which is quite important the Left
Post the right post and your kick
position that you may or may not shoot
wherever you choose there is a circle
that goes through those three there's a
thing that people learn is cool about
circles with a whole bunch of circle
theorems circles have beautiful
properties and one of those properties
is in play right here because this
circle crosses the blue dotted line
there
that's why I went through that but it
also crosses here
and if I draw the other angle from there
we've got in the UK GCSE level Circle
theorem going on here we've got a
segment
um or rather a chord across a circle the
segments the other side of it subtending
an angle on the edge of the circle
and the theorem says that
angle subtended off the same chord are
the same now this is nothing to do with
where you've kicked from but it's
showing us that if you chose to kick
from there you would get the same result
which means whatever distance you choose
there is another place where you get the
same angle maybe this is not a surprise
closely and it's going to be narrow and
really far away is going to be narrow so
you're seeing those pairings and the
circle is backing us up
but here's another observation so if the
circle is really big you can have a long
thin angle come out here and the angle
is going to be small if the circle is
small then the angle is going to be
bigger what we want to do is minimize
this circle and you might begin to see
from this diagram how you could do that
it's easier to see if we make it move so
let me show you on on the moving version
here turn on the circle here that's the
same Circle you can see that I drew and
you see that it's drawn both angles I've
got so let's make these angles even more
separate you can see if the angle is
really small the sort of pairing angle
is further away
I mean I don't want to drop the spoiler
in here but maybe Brady have an instinct
about how to make that angle bigger like
what what would you want to be true
about these two angles for that to be as
big as possible well I feel like it
should be the point where they're on top
of each other where the circle touches
the line yeah there yeah bingo I mean
certainly if you look at the numbers
we're at nine degrees there it's going
down that way and it goes up back nine
then it goes down again that way
there must be one angle that doesn't
appear twice or that's the same angle to
us it and it's exactly what you said
about touching uh technical math word
tangent that where that line is a
tangent to the circle is going to be
where the top two versions of the angle
coincide and we've got the biggest
possible outcome and that means we've
got a really simple geometry problem to
solve and that's it so let's solve it
it's quite hard to actually draw this
because it's not obvious to me where the
circle is that you said needs to just
touch it but it's got to be sort of just
touching here so eyeballing it some
something like that sort of touching
isn't it
close nothing number four sketches what
have I said this before number four
maths is the art of reasoning from Bad
drawings so the angle here the the point
that we're after is the angle where
there's the point where both of these
angles have coincided this has got to be
just touching which also means we get a
another Circle theorem kicking in which
is means that the radius of the circle
is at right angles to the tangent and
that's another Circle theorem you learn
age 16 roughly in the UK and there's one
other fact which is now true that wasn't
true before which is that that distance
X is now the radius of the circle which
means any other line from the center to
the edge is also a radius and also X so
in particular that line there is X and
if I draw one extra line we mentioned
before this this center of the post is
really kind of the center of everything
so if that's on here you realize that
this
is a right angle triangle
and we know some things we know this
distance is D over 2. in natural
practice is 2.8 meters this distance
here is y it's the sort of parallel
version here and we know that part of
the triangle is now X and that's crucial
because we've got a right angle triangle
we know all three sides Pythagoras is
waiting for us I'm just going to write
down Pythagoras's Theorem on this
triangle we've got x squared equals y
squared
Plus
D over 2 squared and we kind of want it
the other way around we want Y in terms
of X so that you put the tray down you
know X how far do you go with Y you get
y equals I'm doing it in one step and
the viewers may be horrified I'm going
to take the this one over and square
everything so it's the square root of x
squared minus D over 2. squared that is
the formula
which every rug to player when they
score a try does not use just to be
clear here so the distance I walk back
to take my kick is
where I scored the try yeah from the
center line yep squared minus half the
width of the goals squared yeah all
square rooted yeah all right I think
that's quite tough to do in your head
even if you memorize the width of the
goals and and I am really Keen to point
out before anyone's like just knocks me
down for being stupid nobody would ever
really want to do that calculation so
they are of modeling things is to get
some sort of rule of thumb which is
maybe a good way to get that calculation
done approximately and I think
approximately is all we're after here
the reason they don't use it and this is
something which I haven't heard talked
about Lots although I'm sure people have
noticed it is that there's a much
quicker way to get very close to that
answer they are of modeling things is to
get some sort of rule of thumb which is
maybe a good way to get that calculation
done approximately and I think
approximately is all we're after here
because there's going to be wind and I'm
going to be tired and kicking up all
everything's going to change the spin of
the ball in the air all sorts of things
are going to change it but we've got a
starting point
but let's have a quick look at what it
looks like if I plot it so on my diagram
here I've got show locus of best spot by
which I mean as I move the try location
around the best spot location
which I'm going to turn on as well
so the best spot you can see actually
let's just move around so you can see
your earlier instincts were pretty good
that's our kick spot the blue one is
marking the best spot so and you can see
the red circle is the one that we
sketched just now it's the tangent
Circle but if I show you how that point
moves as you drag the try location
around
unsurprisingly it's getting close to the
goal as you get close but then something
funky happens there that's hard to tell
so let's just trace this point which is
this
the yellow line is the locus of the best
points it is not a straight line has a
funky curve here
in fact this is a hyperbola
it's a rectangular hyperbola it looks
straight from here it is kind of
straight if I spin this round or maybe
view from the top you can see
if I zoom out
that it has this this curve as you get
close but then it does look like it's
pretty straight and there's a reason for
that because the hyperbola has an
asymptote and you probably recognize a
hyperbola and I'm sure you don't need me
to point out but let's point it out
anyway the graph of one over X
looks like this in fact there's another
one down here it's that sort of shape
we're after it has asymptotes going on
here in fact the one we're looking at is
a little bit more like it's um
heading off
in that direction
is if that's the center of the of the
posts
but the the point is the hyperbola has
an asymptote and it is a straight line
as you go in the long distance and
here's the catch if you look back at the
formula
if x is Big here then as you increase X
this D just never increases and so you
could maybe arrange for X to be super
big it would just dominate this thing
and basically it's irrelevant if you
cover that up you've got y equals the
square root of x squared otherwise known
as
Y equals X
which is a 45 degree line
which means if I go back to my diagram
and sketch the 45 degree line
it's pretty much that line in fact if I
show the rule of thumb which is me just
plotting a 45 degree line on here
this red line running down here is
pretty much exactly the same in fact
it's overlapping for most of the pitch
the only place where it doesn't overlap
and the Curve Kicks in is really close
to the goal and my advice is
you're too close to the goal anyway at
that point so here's the rule of thumb
and I don't actually know if rugby
players are thinking this but 45 degrees
from the center of the goal posts which
means pacing which is what you said
earlier is dead simple if you Pace down
10 Paces where you put the try down
Pace out 10 pieces there's a few catches
though because modeling is what this is
assuming uh all sorts of things like
that you can kick it far enough
and I think if you start to get into the
Realms of like asking me to kick it then
maybe my actual range would start to
mean that how if even if that's the best
angle it'd be much better for me to be
closer because I'm rubbish
uh what's the wind doing
and there's a big kicker which we
haven't pulled down I'm not going to do
it but
we're in a three-dimensional world and
we've been doing it as if we're just
looking down flat and actually the angle
we want to measure to the posts is not
flat on the ground
it's up a bit because the crossbar
because the crossbar you've got to clear
the crossbar as well and I think that
would change the analysis I think it
does doesn't change the outcome very
much but this is what modeling does you
start to include the complexities life
gets a lot harder and you maybe only
make a tiny incremental gain in advice
and I think at this point the inaccuracy
is out on a pitch when you're tired and
the wind's blowing means that 45 degree
rule of thumb is a pretty good way
forward and uh that's what I'm going to
do every time I play badly rugby from
now on
one brush up on all things angle related
with this trigonometry course from
brilliant I feel like I shouldn't admit
this but I can't really remember how PSI
and cosine and tan work never mind
brilliant has me covered
and their courses are so interactive you
can see what I mean here love this stuff
Brilliance just bursting with courses
lessons and questions to get your brain
buzzing and they're adding more stuff
all the time they cover all manner of
complexity and ability whatever you want
you're gonna find it and if you're
already using it why not give brilliant
as a gift to that Learner in your life
there's a 20 discount when you sign up
with our URL brilliant.org number file
that's down in the description and they
also have a 30-day trial so you can give
it a test run see what you think I've
met numerous people who work at
brilliant and they're all so passionate
about these creations about making
people smarter and I also appreciate
them sponsoring this number file video
so as I just discussed that this should
be more than twice this and so now we
can compute the the cross ratio for
these four points and for these four
points and I should get the same answer
so that's as quick as it can happen so
safe now there's a red card we could
research a fact about that record say it
might be the player's eighth rig card
only two players I've got more